Zeke magar will has every reason to
smile his leadership of the Social
Democrats is currently undisputed and
friction within the parliamentary party
has given way to a period of harmony
he's the man of the moment in the SPD a
bit surprising given the disappointing
results of September's national
elections the SPD scored less than
twenty six percent raising expectations
that Gabrielle would vacate the seat of
chairman but that didn't happen instead
Gabrielle led Explorer she coalition
talks with the Conservatives projecting
confidence he warned that if the talks
failed his party was not afraid of
another term in opposition he won over
inner party skeptics by promising a
rank-and-file vote the Madrid espadrille
SPD members have a say in key decisions
such as the formation of a new
government nitsa and shaidan a risky
strategy but so far it's worked
Gabrielle has never been so popular in
the party once regarded as erratic and a
leader who could blindside his own party
with controversial proposals his
relations with other SPD leaders were
strained now it seems those days are
long over Gabrielle is on good terms
with the Chancellor they work together
in the last grand coalition from 2005 to
2009 Darla was Merkel's Environment
Minister these are pictures from a visit
to Greenland
he also gets along with Horst Seehofer
the leader of the CDU's bavarian sister
party the CSU both men are viewed as
experienced strategists Gabrielle and
Marco currently have a lot to talk about
if they seal a deal on a grand coalition
is likely zigma Gabrielle will become
Merkel's deputy Chancellor and labor
minister